GUEST SPEAKER 1: My name is My
name is Abraham, this is Jason.
Jason, Kevin,
[INAUDIBLE] And our team
was called Speed Racers, and
that now it's called the "Cat's
Cradle."
That's the name of the game.
The change of the name was like
a learning experience, at least
the way I see it.
And I'm sure my teammates
will expand on this.
So last week, when we did
the little two-day project,
one of the, I
guess, the pitch we
took was to make a racing game.
And we had this
plan that we were
going to use the
roll ball physics
simulation mechanic
to make it two
simple wheels for an object.
And in trying to solve...
it ended up being a
little harder than that.
And next week we
decided which is going
to expand on that
same project and try
to finish the racing [INAUDIBLE]
And the components that we
tried to figure out and that
we came up with making a game
is something like a fail
state, things that change
speed, ramps, and [INAUDIBLE]
But of the big
debate and the reason
why it's called "Cat's Cradle"
now rather than "Speed Racers"
is because we actually
figured out how to make,
well Jason figured out
a way to make a car,
like a functioning you
go forward, you go left,
you go right.
And there was this conversation
what like two days ago, where
it having the more basic
two balls [INAUDIBLE]
moving something
forward was awkward.
It didn't feel as
good as the car.
And we had to make a
choice whether we're
going to do the car,
which was a little more--
it was softer and nicer to
play with, but also not that
interesting, or
change our premise
and abandon the racing
game and instead
keep pushing for
the notion of we
have two balls and
these move awkwardly.
And so now we have this
awkwardly moving game.
How can we make that you know,
funny or fun or interesting?
And so that's why we
have "Cat's Cradle."
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: You
want to show the Kinect?
STUDENT: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: So now instead
of having a racing car that
is very cool and on fire, you
have this fun cat [INAUDIBLE]
and the awkwardness
of the mechanic
became a funny thing
as [INAUDIBLE]..
And so it was a lesson
on [INAUDIBLE] awkward
because we could make the
most amazing [INAUDIBLE]
mechanics [INAUDIBLE].
Jason did it.
Jason made a beautiful
functioning car.
We decided it was better
to have this physics-based,
roll a ball.
Two things [INAUDIBLE] and
to just make it [INAUDIBLE]..
Two [INAUDIBLE] physics and the
programming aspect of it all.
So that was the big
design [INAUDIBLE]
have something awkward so we
design for the alternative
[INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So
yeah, this looks hard
than it is because [INAUDIBLE]
if you click on the [INAUDIBLE]
So in a way, it [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a [INAUDIBLE] So
if I move the right one,
he will turn left.
And if I move the left,
you'll move to the right.
So I can move them
both in unison
so that it will go straight.
Yeah, so [INAUDIBLE]
and kind of wiggle it
around just moving forward.
So excited [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And actually
we have a version of it
that works with Kinect.
Right now, this is
working [INAUDIBLE]..
And it's a very different
experience but not
necessarily one that
makes it better or worse.
This is that if we
embrace the awkward,
you know, [INAUDIBLE]
moving [INAUDIBLE]
awkwardly and moving
[INAUDIBLE] actually,
the fact that it's
a little harder
makes it funnier
looking at your pushing
and pulling as trying to test.
So we can try the
the Kinect version
to see how that [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: But
yeah, that was the--
I think that was the
big realization--
like, work with what you have
and see [INAUDIBLE] doesn't
deliver what you think was
reported at the beginning
actually can become a new thing
that has its own mistakes.
We tried, like, a very
nice car like thing
with the cat [INAUDIBLE].
It's just-- it felt like
we've seen that game before.
Like, a very nice car
moving around-- it's
like, we've seen that.
A cat [INAUDIBLE] where two,
like, awkward [INAUDIBLE]
are carrying around
a thing with big cat
almost like the discovery of
more [INAUDIBLE] So here's
the cat.
The cat's [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Using the Kinect--
GUEST SPEAKER 3:
Yeah, so because
we decide to have not
seen on the player,
so this is actually
a simpler track,
not like the one that
is so challenging.
[INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Can we do an
amazing work with the camera?
Those of you who saw
the prototype, the guy
was standing around
like a crazy.
And now he's
falling [INAUDIBLE]..
GUEST SPEAKER 2: And the
Kinect is just plugged in.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: It is.
STUDENT: Is it on?
[INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Put up. reset.
Hopefully it runs [INAUDIBLE]
happening [INAUDIBLE]
come on, come on.
And it feels like
you're pushing the bin.
GUEST SPEAKER 3:
And the reason we
have here two
separate projects is
because we tried combining
both projects into one,
but we had a lot of conflicts.
[INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: I think
the next iteration will
have [INAUDIBLE] he's
testing the mechanics to make
it a little smoother, you know,
add some animations so there
is more feedback.
Right now, the feedback
is a little limited.
I think that the [INAUDIBLE]
like their suffering
a lot more than what
they look like right now.
And--
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
[INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]..
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Sorry?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: While
that is going through,
do you guys have any questions?
What do you guys think?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So yeah, it's
[INAUDIBLE] there it goes.
STUDENT: It's the hand charge
are not on a flat surface
that they can't get
friction to move forward.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Right
now, the [INAUDIBLE]
are just-- it's just a mesh
that is replacing [INAUDIBLE]
object that is
acute that has been
pushed around [INAUDIBLE] body.
STUDENT: So if it [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: It can
move longer, anything.
And it does [INAUDIBLE]
a new version of it,
I would like to-- would have had
time to animate the hedgehogs
and try the steps
and can do something
a little more
advanced like that.
STUDENT: You said, like-- spread
your arms out a little more.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Ah,
good, [INAUDIBLE]..
STUDENT: Because they're
in front of the shoulders.
STUDENT: I don't know, it's--
I think it's because
the tables here.
But it's having
trouble tracking.
[INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
OK, we'll try again.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Here you Are.
Oh no!
We also [INAUDIBLE] that, like,
following this [INAUDIBLE],,
it will be interesting to see
[INAUDIBLE] like a big cat with
two [INAUDIBLE] these two
[INAUDIBLE] are carrying around
a big cake--
something like that.
And you have, like,
anything-- and you're
having to control these
two characters [INAUDIBLE]..
A new version
would probably have
also a cat that is deattached
and has some sort of physics.
And you can drop
him and [INAUDIBLE]
very angry-- you know,
something like that.
Keep exploring that notion.
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: What's the white stuff?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: He
is just very salty.
It's just like, they're
angry, and like, you know,
stuff comes out [INAUDIBLE]
replaces with, like, swear word
[INAUDIBLE].
He is, I can't
believe you're doing
this [INAUDIBLE] you know.
But right now, it's just
like [INAUDIBLE] particle
because [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Initially,
we also wanted so that--
such that if the cat
tumbles down and then
the cat will be susceptible to
beat the gravity and just like
rolls down [INAUDIBLE] of these.
But when we did that, like,
everything just broke.
Like, when you press play, that
cat just flew to outer space.
So we had to remove
that feature.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: This is amazing
to see a cat [INAUDIBLE]..
GUEST SPEAKER 2: It is actually
not tracking that well.
STUDENT: I was watching
this work way better
when you guys were--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: It was kind
of fun yesterday making it.
It feels like you're a big head.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Because it
was started one zero position
where you position yourself.
So the next thing
you need to do is
to move forward
in the z direction
closer to the Kinect such
that it increase exact value.
And then the thing should
actually propel you forward.
And if you go backward to that
zero [INAUDIBLE] position,
it should actually go behind.
So it's like two
differential wheel.
If you want to steer
yourself, you just
move your leg backward
and your right forward
or some [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 3: I wanted
to just show you the cat
because it's funny looking.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, you
can actually take a look
at the artwork here.
[INAUDIBLE] actually making--
put in a lot of effort making
this--
GUEST SPEAKER 3: He's
just like this angry cat.
Ugh!
He's so angry.
And--
STUDENT: So this is
not a standard asset.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: No.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
scratching [INAUDIBLE]..
And he spent like two days.
GUEST SPEAKER 3:
I should probably
should have spent more
time doing something
to help the game actually
work a little smoother.
But I figure, like, if we
have something awkward,
we can just make something
awkward to move with it.
And so those two [INAUDIBLE]
of that angry cat,
they became the
"Cat's Cradle" game.